german chancellor angela mackle has
called on russian president vladimir
putin to pull back his forces from
russia's border with ukraine
the white house says russia now has more
troops there than at any time since
conflict broke out in eastern ukraine in
2014.
the buildup has fueled fears of new
fighting but russia insists
that it is the victim of western
provocations
[Music]
russian state television offers a
different way of looking at things
it reports that ukraine and nato pose a
threat to russia
and not the other way round the
narrative presents ukrainian soldiers as
the aggressors
and shows video footage of moscow's
response
russian troops engaged in military
exercises in crimea
what to the west looks like sabre
rattling is viewed differently by russia
for moscow it's a necessary
reinforcement of its defenses against
the west
the majority of the ukrainian military
understand the fatal consequences of any
actions that would lead to conflict
i hope they won't be provoked by
politicians who in turn are being
provoked by the west
especially the united states
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
sees western troops especially those
provided by nato
as essential backup for his own forces
everyone can see it when our soldiers
are attacked and there are casualties
obviously we must retaliate
a few days ago zelensky paid a visit to
nato secretary general
jens stoltenberg zielinski stressed that
the western military alliance is
ukraine's only way to end the war in
donbass
experts in moscow say that statement
would not have gone down well in the
kremlin
any cooperation between ukraine and nato
any help from the north atlantic
alliance
is a red flag for the kremlin
but that doesn't mean that all members
of the alliance welcome ukraine's desire
to join nato as soon as possible
right now further steps towards
membership are not on the agenda
a clear statement that gives many in
russia hope that a war is preventable
the people of donbass are less
optimistic
though the pro-russian separatists
insist they don't want war
either no
if ukraine takes the first step nobody
knows where it will end
the kremlin is doing all this to
blackmail ukraine
and the west
if troops are reinforced if the
escalation continues
even a small provocation will be enough
to set things off
with unpredictable consequences
russia's defense ministry says this
footage shows recent
exercises if the situation escalates
tv screens may soon be showing the real
thing
let's bring in our correspondent yuri
rashetto in moscow
yuri it was suggested in that report
there that russia's
saber-rattling is part of an effort to
blackmail ukraine
and the west can you explain the
rationale behind that
well terry the experts i spoke to see
several reasons for that first of all
they all say that russia doesn't want to
annex donbass as it once did with crimea
instead moscow sees donbass as a part of
ukraine but on
its own russian terms and that means
under largely russian control
through the politics in donbas moscow
could put pressure on all ukrainian
politics
that's what moscow obviously wants uh
the ukrainian president zelensky
understands that and that is why he has
changed his tactics towards russia in
the beginning he used to be looking for
a dialect with moscow
now he is choosing a completely
different tone and wants a nato
membership
the second reason is there has been
heavily heavy pressure on the program
than politicians in ukraine in recent
months
all russia friendly tv channels for
example were closed by president
zelinski
putin didn't like that and now he's
obviously taking revenge
the next reason is the significantly
worse relations with the west
the verbal exchange with u.s president
joby who called putin a murderer
putin never forgets something like that
and finally there is also the upcoming
parliamentary elections in russia terry
the kremlin apparently needs a new
agenda that distracts from it
internal russian problems and seeks an
enemy from outside and here once again
ukraine fits very well as such an enemy
okay so that explains the context very
well but
russia does have these troops now masked
at the ukrainian border has it indicated
how long it plans to keep them there
well russia repeats again again that the
troops are on
russian territory and moscow would be
allowed to do everything possible with
them that's true
also russia can't disregard donbass
because if it doesn't intervene in this
situation
the next issue could be crimea from the
russian point of view and the loss of
donbass could result in further
political losses for russia
on the other hand terry there is a risk
of getting involved in a war with the
almost whole west given that russia has
no allies or even
sympathizers in the entire western world
we can assume how
the possible voting in the u.n will turn
out for moscow in case of
war the situation for russia can become
extremely complicated
the consequences to put it mildly
unpredictable ultimately
experts believe it would be better if
moscow stops the zebel rattling as soon
as possible
what's being done yuri to avoid further
escalation
in this conflict
well obviously the minsk peace agreement
doesn't work anymore ukraine in
particular
no longer seems to feel obliged to
implement it but russians too
insist on their own interpretation but
there is i think still a chance that
this problem can be resolved through
negotiations for that i think a new
model has to be found
and the west could moderate this
negotiation process again
germany and france have been sitting on
uh at a negotiation table with ukrainian
ukraine and russia for years and seemed
to be accepted by both sides
perhaps the americans would have to come
along but on the other hand russians
wouldn't like that so it means
or it remains an extremely difficult
conflict in the middle of europe
yuri thank you very much as always dw's
moscow correspondent yuri rochetto
you